[Music]
this is crazy this is our first bonus
episode of good for you yeah this is
like we're calling an emergency episode
with the two smartest people I know well
I'm an expert on you're on but that's it
but not really I mean I'm an expert
among commute comedians I would be
you're the most educated of the
comedian's
about Iran it's a good niche to have I
got one yeah exactly
I am lucky enough to be friends with
Jessica Yellen who is the only person I
trust in news and awful I did art
I discovered you around the last
election a lot of people I think we're
so sick of being yelled at and having
their news be subjective and opinionated
and everything kind of being spin that
everyone's like you just got to follow
Jessica yes I and you were doing these
Instagram stories where you delivered
the news and a very clear non-emotional
who knew the woman was going to be the
least emotional people in news clearly
in a way where I was like okay I can
talk about this at a dinner party she
just said it in a way and so I just
plagiarized you amazing two years and
now everyone thinks I know what I'm
talking about good that's the goal make
everybody smart so you can talk about
the information and make decisions so
Jessica as most people know she was a
White House correspondent for CNN for
how long well I covered the White House
for about four and a half years and I
covered oba I was the chief White House
correspondent under Obama and I covered
the Bush White House before that right I
covered all of DC for 10 years Capitol
Hill domestic politics you name it
everything awful happening I was there
now she's here with us yes and she has a
book out it's called savage news get it
follow her on Instagram it's just at
Jessica Yellin and the hashtag is news
not noise which I love so much no I'm
obsessed with you it's awesome I mean my
whole theory is that we're so drowning
in noise we don't know what really
matters and how to take it in and so if
you can just pinpoint the clearest
information
that will make your life better mm-hmm
that'll make a difference I just shut
down when I watch the news now I feel
like you have to watch five different
networks you have to read five different
articles and the truth is somewhere in
between you know I feel like I'm getting
a lot of opinions and I'd and I don't I
just want the fact there's so much
outrage also it gets exhausting okay and
there's so much clickbait I mean I
understand that now you know news
networks are businesses at this point
and they want you to click on the thing
they want you to keep watching and I
it's so crazy to me that that you know
CNN all these networks are supposed to
be neutral they have these opening
graphics with an American flag waving
and like an eagle flies in on CNN it's
always breaking news and I'm like poor
wolf Blitzer's you'd be sitting there
with breaking news for the past 20 years
but it looks like a Michael Bay movie
yet it looks like an action movie
you know WWF like in this corner
totally Bernie Sam yeah this summer the
news well there's no longer you know I
think I heard I don't know who was one
of these politicians maybe was Obama he
was bright and somebody was saying how
there was a time when we agreed on the
facts oh yeah and we no longer do and as
you said left right what side you're
listening to you're gonna get a totally
different spin on it I said about
Jessica once I was you know I was talk
about you to people and tell them to
follow you and I found myself one night
saying someone no but like her facts are
true like she's got true facts like if
you wanted the true facts go to her I
think the difference is do you give
people context because sometimes you
just get these facts air bombed on you
yeah you don't know what to do with it
like tons of people are protesting in
Hong Kong okay if I live in the middle
of America why does that matter to me
real rights and to give people larger
context makes such a difference and
that's what we miss a lot of time and I
think somet many news organizations have
baggage with Donald Trump that even when
they're delivering news but they're sort
of rolling their eyes at him and they're
sort of throwing jabs at him which it
just all feels very performative loaded
and emotional and biased it's also as
you guys know being in this is that
whether you're comedian are worth
whether in the news when you were when
you're delivering it or you're in a
panel it's quick talking jumping in got
to be quick it's hard to get a deep dive
that's why I show like let's say John
all
show is great to watch because he really
does a Deep Diver sometimes I watch
Rachel Maddow and I feel like I'm
watching a lesson the political science
class because I'm gonna hope she's
diving deep and you get what you just
said which is context which is something
that for me it bothers me when I hear
for example though being in Iran in
America and the whole Iran thing and and
you know Trump saying we took soleimani
out he was a terrorist that this at the
other and then I'm listening to Howard
Stern and Stern has on first he has on
one guy who had served in the military
who's got the context and he starts
breaking down the context then they
bring on Sal who supposedly doesn't know
much at all but he's just going yeah we
got a terrorist and you know and I'm
thinking maybe they'll just get another
another guy will come in who's gonna be
more reasonable and stern was like what
are you talking about this was a general
in a military he wasn't a terrible
memory of a terrorist organization yes
America had called it a terrorist
organization but still it's an actual
military so we was just saying having
some context as to who and what we don't
have a lot of that well this is how
little I know about the situation is I
need context for the context you just
gave me like I need even I need to get
even more granular which is what I
wanted to do this podcast with the two
smartest people I know about this
situation because I'm having a really
hard time understanding the situation
and I want to just get super granular
about it and I want to just create a
safe space ask very stupid question
thing I'm gonna ask very stupid
questions because I think a lot of
people aren't afraid to be embarrassed a
lot of people are afraid to not know you
know and I think there's a lot of times
where I'm like watching the news I'm
like okay I need a basic understanding
of that I don't even know what that is
like I can't even understand what's
going on I think a lot of people are
very busy people have jobs they don't
have time to constantly be educating
themselves about this so I just want to
like get right into it
first question how do you pronounce a
wrong I really got it is it Ron I would
say like imagine you it's the you know
just the letter e and then a guy named
Ron Iran that's it
got it and to me as an Iranian American
I was born in Iran I grew up in America
Iran is like fingernails on a
rock board like don't do I read whenever
people's especially when but when
leaders you know senators presidents
anybody goes Iran or whatever even when
Bush was when we're gonna war with iraq
and he would say Iraq
yeah it's Iraq it's Iran II like someone
saying cement cement knowing a crown you
know America I don't go like a merica
you know it's just to me it just sounds
like I you know again I grew up in
America and and I'm pretty good with
like when I learn a foreign language I'm
pretty good with getting close to that
accent yeah but some of my American
friends have horrible accents so yeah so
the span is like hola Khmer song so
that's the same thing like Iran is just
like Iran may I ask one how do you say
soleimani
so they so you you got to get you were
very it's just so lame on solely money
money you can Soleimani cuz what's again
what's funny to me is and again as a
comedian I'm looking for some comedy in
this tragedy that's happened with war
and then the airplane being shot down
and stuff but I go put some comedy I can
think of is so last night I remember I
was watching I think it was John Kerry
was on lawrence O'Donnell and a couple
times as they were talking about
Soleimani
they called him salami and I was saying
I was saying as a middle Easterner it's
nice what I go it's entertaining to us
watching you guys struggle with our name
well I think that there is a big
misunderstanding and or just lack of
information ignorant a lot of people
some of them in this room that hosts
this podcast around that region in
general I was talking to some of the
other night who said well we've been at
war with them since the 90s like Desert
Storm and I was like no that's a
different country yeah you know can you
just give us like a little bit of
context of our history with this region
in general okay
well I'll say that the CIA the first
time the CIA took out created a coup in
another country was 1953 in Iran mmm-hmm
so our back-and-forth with them goes
back a long long time they had a Shah in
power who's like a monarch and there was
someone else coming up who was trying to
take money
an oil away from the West and the CIA
said weren't having that and we
intervened and kept down and his name
was Mossad dead so Mossad dead this guy
was so Iran was like you said it was a
monarchy but it also had a parliament so
Mossad dead was the leader of the
Parliament so imagine like in England
right now you've got your Prime Minister
then you got the Queen
so the Shah was the king and and and at
the time there was actually he goes even
further a lot of people I know watch
Shahs of Sunset yes the idea of that
being a royal term has gotten confused
yeah so Shah is another word for
basically of the king and so the Shah
the the the Charlotte was in power in
the early 50s
his father had become the Shah before
that and his father coming out of World
War one I believe the Western powers
came together and said okay this guy
will play ball with us he will let us
have a lot of the oil this was the
British at the time we'll let us have
the oil so there was a lot of oil in
Iran because I think we'll think of
Saudi Arabia muscle yeah shit shits
coming yeah when you got oil is I used
to say this is like being a drug dealer
you gotta know when to flush it down the
toilet coming yeah yeah and so it's not
just is it Saudi Arabia its Iran it's
all these countries but the question
becomes will they play ball with you so
the so the the Shahs father who was the
king at the time coming out of World War
one played some ball with them and also
was also westernizing Iran somewhat then
what happened was in World War two I
don't feel about them you know about
this but Iranians the word Iran comes
from Aryan so we come from the caucus
mountains we are the original white
people we we are originally would be the
ad for 23andme yeah so Iranians a lot of
Iranians now in America too when people
go like well you know you're Arab big
I'm not Arab where he running which is
different ethnically well I think the
word Arab I think is times up on Arab
right well no there's Arabs Arabs are
Arabs right I mean and then and then
ethically Iranians are very sensitive
it's like telling a Cuban you're Mexican
they like what Gulf Arabs versus non
Gulf Arabs right versus the Persian
culture but yeah I feel like my uncle
like older uncle
and grandpa they say Arab and you get
like no well there are Arabs I mean
there when they talk about rocks but
Iran's Iran ease aren't Arab Ronnie's
come from like I said that the caucus
mountains and with were Caucasian and so
they the Persians the other Persians
that Empire was called Persia but anyway
what happens was in World War two the
Shahs father who had been cooperating
with the West with America and the Brits
and the oil and all that stuff he starts
going well we are Iranian we're Aryan so
I kind of get what Hitler's talking
about so the shots father starts kind of
sympathizing with Hitler and then the
West is like whoa what's up with that so
then they go okay you gotta get we're
gonna get rid of you you're gonna go in
exile we're gonna put your son in power
and that was the Shah that you were
talking about who at the age of 21 Swiss
educated all this stuff he becomes this
king of this country and people Iran
ian's themselves like this guy's a boy
like who is this guy so at that point
that's when this guy Mossad dead who was
the like an older politician who had who
was experienced he had enough strength
to stand up to the Shah and go no no the
21 year old the 21 year old and go no
we're gonna run the country I was
elected democratically and not only that
but we're going to nationalize our oil
we're gonna kick the Brits out of here
and we're going to take our oil back and
that's when the Brits go to the
Americans the coup that you were talking
about 1953 they go to the Americans and
they go hey Iran is trying to kick us
out and by the way Iran is located
strategically to the north of them is
the Soviet Union
we're at the Cold War at that time so
the Brits tell the Americans ago you
know if Iran kicks us out then the
Soviets will take over in Iran will go
communist so hey America you need to get
involved and help us overthrow Mossad
death it all goes back to Russia and oil
every time every time every time why I
mean I went to college like why didn't
someone just explain it to me that
clearly I guess I guess that's why
you're comedian and because we do
because American you know we are so I
I feel at least I you know I I just the
other day I was asked my kids go to a
private school they asked me to come and
speak about Islamophobia and I was there
talking about my experiences as an
Iranian American growing up in America
and the kids were so advanced and they
were asking questions yeah but I told
them I said you know when I was your age
nobody was coming and talking to us
about any other point of view of history
except for what was in the books yeah so
I didn't really learn much about I
didn't know about the coup d'etat until
I was in college and I studied it and I
go oh wow America overthrew a Democratic
democratically elected leader in Iran oh
no wonder why Iran ian's feel that
America is behind everything so there's
a history of American interference would
that be fair to say yes and I'm so glad
you're here because I do have some
questions in general about the culture
of the Iranian people from what I
ascertain they don't love interference
is that is that I mean it's you know our
country has pride I think I'm patriotic
I would say but I think you know because
we have free speech because we have a
free press we are allowed to criticize
we're also a younger country from the
people I know there's pride and you know
witches will get to the cultural
monuments thing in a second there is
pride around the country and American
interference probably isn't ideal is
that fair to say I mean a thousand
percent I think that's partly cultural
and also our history of intervention has
been so toxic yeah is there I mean we
could talk in detail but flash-forward
we supported Iraq in a big war against
Iran Iran and Iraq were locked in this
battle the death toll from that was
astronomical there were chemical weapons
used and we backed Iraq against Iran we
had this history of taking sides again
with the Shah the monarch and having a
relationship with them where we're
taking their oil and personally
profiting and at the expense of the
people right so there's not just a
resentment that's cultural but just a
structural economic problem that the
West is benefiting and it's not
benefiting the people of Iran and and
the people of Iran are very proud like
you just said we're very proud of you're
not in a pejorative way I think there's
just it's there's so much history there
you know we're proud of our history the
prodigal you said the Persian Empire was
a
empire I mean I think Iran Ian's talk
about that we had Kings who Cyrus the
Great his supposedly he was one of the
first leaders who was benevolent in that
when he would take over another country
he would allow them to practice their
religion I don't know how much truth
there is to this how much what but but
basically that's what we say and so
there's a there's a cylinder it's called
the Cyrus cylinder which is you're
driving on Santa Monica and Century City
you see this big lights and this is this
weird thing like on your left hand side
right as you're approaching Beverly
Hills on little Santa Monica there's a
little sign with a regular some
everything is on the left hand side near
the mall there's this weird thing that
looks like just like it's just lit it's
just like what is that that's the Cyrus
cylinder but no so so Cyrus and then
supposedly his the the Charter for the
United Nations is something that came
from Cyrus too great the whole thing of
human rights and so Iran is are very
proud of our history and the fact is
that Iran before the Revolution of 1979
which was the Islamic Revolution Iran
originally wasn't even Muslim Iran's
original religion was the Rashtriya nism
which is what is that Freddie Mercury if
you remember Freddie Mercury in the
movie in the movie the Freddie Mercury
what it was called he he says I think
his father at one point says good
thoughts good words good deeds and
that's what they believed zoroastrians
so rationalism was one of the first
monotheistic religions in the world so
all these other monotheistic it might be
this I know that there was all kinds of
rituals and stuff but basically you know
if you look at Christianity if you look
at Islam all this other stuff works you
see Scientology it Hall comes I mean it
can all be traced back to zero Astra
anism
so Iran ian's have this are very proud
of that culture and then they actually
one of the reasons the Iranians have a
problem with like the sometimes Iran is
can be racist against Arabs in that I
think that they feel like the air was
brought Islam to us and now we are
suffering under the Islamic Republic
there's also another layer we should
bring out
there's this division within Islam
between the Shiite and the Sunni Muslims
and it's different branches of Islam is
there an equal comparison to that
protestant-catholic great thank you
yeah so one point what happened was
going down Islam as you go down the
genealogy of it
the Sunnis say oh it should be the
father-in-law of Mohammed whose name I
believe was Abu Bakr and then the
Iranians say no it should be one of the
sons or I forget what the actual
genealogies but it's like the guy named
Ali and so they start to split and the
difference in practicality is that in
the Sunni religion it's not as
hierarchical it is I mean there are
obviously people that are more educated
in it and you know you go to but in the
Shiite religion for sure there's a
hierarchy so the shared religion is a
little closer to what Catholicism might
be which is like we have you know
kaatham has the Pope right so the Pope
knows more he's closer to God so in Iran
they've got the Supreme Leader slap a
bitch on a red car so Iran has what what
they had home a knee yeah
and now they have commnity the names are
very similar yeah but the different
people who is quote-unquote the supreme
leader and but how can I repeat that at
a party so the politics of it are
basically the Sunni countries band
together mm-hmm in the Middle East and
the Shiite against the Shiite forces and
Iran is the most powerful Shiite force
in the Middle East and then you look at
Saudi Arabia and Iraq and UAE they're
Sunni so they all gather together
against Iran you put Iraq in there Iraq
is actually majority Shiite but ruled by
what was that was being run by Saddam
Hussein which going back as you know
when when we were going to war with Iraq
under Bush in 2003 number two I I'm
shocked that they did not have somebody
advising them I'm sure they did that
said they said wait a minute you know if
you go and get rid of Saddam that the
Iranians will easily be able to come in
to Iraq and stir up unrest and some
arrests but also because there was a
a minority of Sunnis so Saddam was a
Sunni minority similarly but like 20%
30% and then and the majority country
was Shiite and the US has allied itself
with the Sunni powers in the Middle East
yes
led by most dominant in among them is
Saudi Arabia but our politics are we
side with the Sunnis they always work
with us on the oil investment etc and as
a counterpoint to Iran and let me just
ask a question this is gonna sound
stupid everything I'm gonna say is gonna
sound really stupid we were not at war
with Iran before this happened we were
at war with Isis or we were at war with
everybody all the time
this fundamental tension I've been
talking about Shia versus Sunni goes
back for decades I see and we have been
in an on-again off-again cold ich war
with Iran since the 70 and that manifest
says having troops there and occupying
it or or siding with their with their
enemies backing their enemies enemies
fight against them so what we haven't
talked about is the Revolution when the
Islam there is a religious power came to
run Iran is the simplest way I think to
say at the Ayatollah Khomeini be in
America would it be like if he'll be
like the religious right take over if
like yeah the Graham family's I mean
Mort more than they have Koch brothers
like if Mike Pence actually were
president or if Trump were actually
actually cared about Iran was also very
westernized intellectuals yeah SIA tea
with Advent you know trout I mean I
don't want to say that this is what
defines sophistication but traveling to
Paris going to the West all their kids
are educated in the US universities and
then you get the ayatollah comes in and
says we're living by religious law and
then overnight women are in hijab and
all over it just shifts i don't want to
make it but it's is it's not Gilead
obviously but it's like in terms of
their it regrets in a way would you say
it went back thousands of years so
basically what happened was as jessie
was saying just to understand the the
history of it so once 53 happens and
they do the coup d'etat Shah comes into
power the Shah was actually modern
near on bringing a lot as you said
there's pictures of Iran in the
seventies sixties women are miniskirts
sir go go go go dudes are doing their
things like as a kid in Iran I remember
like American culture first of all let
me just say one thing
Iran Ian's love American culture we love
the movies we love the sports all that
stuff and Iranian people love Americans
and there's obviously a faction of
Iranians who probably support the regime
and they go well whatever they say I got
a do so death to America but they could
care less really like they're just
trying to live their lives so I remember
as a kid like like I saw rocky rocky and
Iran I was a kid I think they manipulate
the movies at all I don't remember I
mean I was a kid I don't think there was
that much censorship going on I think it
was pretty it was pretty open but the
problem was so the Shah has people that
liked him and people that didn't like
him because the one thing was end of the
day yes he was modernizing it there was
definitely movements in the right
direction but at the same time if you
were an enemy of the charr you
criticized the Shah you could disappear
pretty fast so what happens is all these
different factions from the religious
group to the let's say the liberals to
the Communists to the whoever would all
of a sudden start saying wait a minute
the Shah is taking away our rights
people are disappearing they had a
secret police called the SAVAK who if
they showed up at your house you were
screwed and so all of these guys come
together and this revolution that
happens in 79 I've talked to people who
were there they said for a couple of
days it was euphoria because everyone
thought oh my god the Shah has left Iran
is free finally we don't have to you
know rely on the West and we've got it
we're gonna have our own democracy just
like we saw in Egypt recently when the
revolution happened during the the Arab
Spring I think a lot of people felt
euphoria for a little bit but then
quickly the person that takes power the
people that take power are the religious
group under homais knee and and it
becomes the Islamic Republic of Iran and
we go back where laws start changing all
of that well I'd have to start covering
up all of us a great book for you and
your listeners to read there's a
two-part audio book for us to listen
listen to no actually it's a
okay no it's actually a it's a not a
comic book but it's a picture book I'm
in it's called persopolis oh yeah this
op was one and two this leaning marjan
satrapy who's a French Iranian she wrote
it and it talks tells her story of
living under that regime because what
happens is when the revolution happens
and they go back a thousand years and
women now got to cover themselves up and
there's there's a you know religious
police that will you know you can't
drink alcohol there's all kinds of stuff
quickly what happens is Khomeini gets a
little cocky and he's like oh this is
gonna be good
we're gonna spread our form of Islam
around the world
Saddam gets cocky cuz he goes oh these
guys have gotten weak I'm gonna go to
that border region where we had the
little oil dispute I'm gonna get my oil
and then Jimena goes well then let's go
to war and as Jessica was saying before
they end up in like a seven or eight
year war we're over a million Iran in
Iraq we're over a million people die in
Iran I'm not sure how many Iraqis died
but American this was in the early 80s
and America was supplying Saddam with
all kinds of weapons and then the
iran-contra things happens and we
realize that we're supplying Iran with
weapons and then I remember reading a
quote I forget who said it but somebody
there was an American ambassador who
said something along the lines Rodman
Dennis Rodman who said we are fine no
the fact is we have no more ambassadors
anymore that's under Trump ambassador
was I did but basically they said what
do we care we're supplying arms to both
sides let them get each other we don't
care okay and to give you just the
bird's eye view of this liked a big
perspective as soon as that revolution
happened Iran said death to America and
Israel must be eliminated so they
immediately become the pariah to the
West and the West in alliance with
Israel is poised against Iran and so
that fuels our alliances in the region
and how we are engaged yes we take both
sides of fights we're doing things
behind the scenes but big picture that's
when we decide Iran's our enemy and
we're in a constant Cold War ish with
them since then and all kinds of things
keep coming up one I mean one of the
things that Iran I
did and now it's kind of come back to
bite this admit this regime in their ass
is that the the current Islamic Republic
of Iran is that they were like you said
Israel is the enemy Israel's the enemy
therefore we're going to arm Hezbollah
or Hamas or whoever's fighting against
the hey what Hezbollah is for someone
who doesn't know can we talk about that
for I mean I think what real really what
you need to understand to understand
where how we got here is they actually
grew these terrorist organizations right
within Iran they decided we are not
going to as a country fight this fight
against America alone we're going to
create and fund and develop a network of
powerful terrorist organizations one of
which is Hezbollah yeah and that will go
out and create skirmishes and commit
violence to advance our interests
without our having our fingerprints on
it which is what they say now with the
proxies that say this proxy wars right
so what define that well similar to what
what you know if you when you when
you're fighting a war with a country
that can fight you the you you fight on
the battlefield but when you're a
country like Iran where you go we can't
take on the superpower America in a war
well then let's get our little listen
let's go into places like Hezbollah is
in Lebanon Hamas is in the path are
Palestinians they've gotten now they're
in Yemen they're in Iraq they have all
these different groups that they're
funding and arming yeah and they're
saying and they're saying we're gonna
give you money we're gonna help you guys
fight the the the allies of our enemies
in these other places or even go after
American soldiers or some of these
places and it's kind of come back to
bite this current Iranian regime in the
ass because a lot of Iranians now in
Iran are going you you know with all the
current sanctions going on your people
are starving but you're taking any money
you have and arming these other groups
put their your money to us yeah and so
it's a strategy that was working for
them and that's where the soleimani guy
comes into play is that he was somebody
who was kind of supervising a lot of
these proxies or and just go
around and make sure running little
terrorist groups listen again I will go
back and say you know obviously they're
carrying out terroristic acts but just
to understand in an objective way it's
kind of like when the Vietcong were
jumping out of trees yeah it's like Iran
is saying they're going like this is the
way this is the only way we can fight
you guys because you guys have your
drones and you have your this and you
have your that you're attacking
countries the way we do well then we're
gonna create what we call a military arm
but you guys are gonna call us
terrorists okay there's one way to look
at it is Iran among the countries in the
Middle East Iran has one of the most
sophisticated organized official
militaries and I think can we see can we
with this as a kind of 83 million people
80 million so yeah and also I think that
people kind of go Iran or rot like we're
so big and we're so much I mean this is
a formidable country with a very middle
of military and I was reading about how
they have incredible scientists working
on nuclear arms and a lot of them were
assassinated I mean this is an
incredible powerful organized organizer
with a real military that's formidable
and that could inflict damage where we
to go to war with them unlike other
countries that are not quite as you know
they buy weapons and they have this
thing here and they could take one plane
down Iran could organize a response they
also have these proxies that they
support these organizations like
Hezbollah and one of the ways in which
our attack on soleimani was shocking and
different is unlike Osama bin Laden or
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi who ran al Qaeda
and Isis respectively they're what we
call non-state actors they ran terrorist
organizations that didn't belong to one
country they were bands that would move
around and work in many countries - you
know inflict violence and you know
create their advance their agenda so
Imani was like the head of a proper
military division he is it would it's
hard my friend tonight to me it's like
imagine if somebody suddenly executed
General Petraeus out of nowhere at the
height of his power I mean that's that
is I really want to nail like what is
the equivalent someone said it would be
like taking out the head of the CIA the
head of FBI and my pesto all-in-one
soleimani as I understand was both the
Petraeus at the height of his
our of this moment but also hugely
influential politically so he wasn't
just a general he also was a public
figure
hmm now and so in that way some people
say it's like taking out Petraeus plus a
VP he wasn't caught he's a controversial
guy it's not like everyone loved him
yeah we'll get into what he did and I
think he oversaw things that you know he
helped grow Hezbollah which enacted
terrorist violence around the region so
that's why the u.s. designated him part
of a terrorist organization but we were
designating Iran's official military a
terrorist organization it would be like
North Korea saying the US military is a
terrorist organization because we're
enemies and I hear that Bush and Obama
both passed on the idea of but Nike is
not because they didn't think he's a bad
guy like I don't care if you I mean yeah
you could defend him about from the us's
perspective in advancing Western
interests Soleimani
was the enemy in a way right he was
executing a will that is at odds with
American interests they passed on taking
him out because they thought that the
danger of retribution was greater than
the danger he posed alive yeah this is
like a multi-dimensional chess game so
Soleimani was a bad guy a lot of
Iranians in Iran didn't like so they
might a matter of fact there was a
picture there was circulating on social
media where someone had written in
Persian damnit gam which means may your
breath remain warm which means like
right on yeah
it's a damage gam Trump like right on
Trump for killing Soleimani so this Iran
Ian's in Iran
there's obviously Iranians who support
the government the regime and they they
thought they saw slowly money as a hero
but there's also a lot of Iranians in
Iran who are fed up with this regime and
they were like right on thanks for
taking this guy out there was definitely
a lot of Iranians outside of Iran people
that I know that we're saying this is
great that we took him out and I
personally don't like solely money I was
like it's I didn't like the guy if he
had if I didn't shed a tear for the guy
yeah however what you were saying the
reason that I think that the bush and
Trump Bush and Obama administrations
didn't take him out was because
they were they were worried about the
repercussions because slowly money has
laid so many different tentacles around
that region and I was worried I mean
I'll tell you is an iranian-american I
know a lot of people were very worried
like our stomachs were turning beyond
the fact that America was gonna go to
war the idea was I'm gonna be an
iranian-american here and Iran is gonna
start hitting I don't know what they're
gonna hit as a matter of fact first of
all there was a breath of friend when
they hit those bases and they said okay
nobody got nobody was killed we thought
okay moving on Iran hit American bases
this was a couple days after in Iraq
yeah as their retribution for the
attacks is their official retribution
they bombed a bunch of Iraqi bases where
US troops were stationed there was no
loss of life on the bases although
they've done must've been intentional
though right so they were both playing
this game or they say it wasn't
intentional but they have such precision
guided missiles fo sho it was intended
and they're saying domestically we
killed 80 people and internationally we
know they didn't because again it's the
official act of Iran what we're all
poised for and waiting for is the
retribution that's going to come from
Hezbollah from these proxies Iran has a
history they're a bit you can think of
it a bit like China where their
strategic patient considered and will
strike at a time that is best for them
and not in the heat of the moment and
then I now understand the history of
American intervention with Iran I now
see this is a very deep-seated loaded
there's a lot of baggage here can we
rewind a little bit to about two months
before this happened I texted you at
2:00 a.m. yeah I texted Jessica at 2:00
a.m. because I have this there's this
you know texting thing now where you can
text people and I give out my phone
number and you can text me and it's you
know mostly for touring and engaging
with your fans and all that and I'm
looking at it and between the dick pics
I'm getting I get I get a bunch of
people saying I'm in Iran and the Wi-Fi
is down and people are being shot in the
streets and they sent me videos of
people getting shot in the streets
protestors getting shot in the streets
and they said will you please post this
and I texted you in a complete panic
because I was like I'm not a journalist
know what this and I posted two of them
because I was just I my heart just broke
and then after the factors I put if
these aren't real what if I'm not a
journalist I'm Way in over my head but
just I ended up posting them anyway and
a lot of people ended up texting me but
can you talk about the Wi-Fi going down
so we can just do this in a timeline of
how yes can I tell you about that
protest and then the larger picture so
the protests were irani ins who are fed
up with the god-awful economic
conditions they're living under their
economy is being suffocated I will say
Soleimani Hood's force thing that he ran
within the military was in part
responsible for the killing of their own
people just to just to really nail that
this is not a man that was a totally
popular writer on again imagine if the
religious right took over yeah and they
started implementing a lot of you know I
was talking to there's an analyst you
know you know Kareem Sajit poor you know
who he is
criticized reporters an analyst he's
really really good you had him on your
podcast he's on my practice yeah so he
he made a good point he said you know
usually totalitarian states are
totalitarian in one form or another
they're either socially totalitarian or
economically totalitarian or they have
you know what whatever it is or
politically totalitarian so he says for
example in China you know politically
totalitarian but you can make money or
you know some people can you can drink
there's a lot of social stuff that that
let you do he said Iran right now this
region area pillow you can marry pillow
Iran Iran the the the the the leadership
there you know when when the Revolution
first happened everybody thought oh wow
I mean it was it was sold to the people
as you know the Shah and his cronies
have been stealing the riches of this
land forever we're gonna redistribute
those riches and not only did that not
happened but I got darker and darker and
darker and so now the people there are
living with there's no political
freedoms so you could be arrested for
all kinds of you we arrested for
protesting is that Reza for president
one of them piss me off when I when I do
Trump jokes on stage and some Americans
get upset they go you can't make fun of
our president that's the whole point of
this country yeah that's all I go use
why these the First Amendment yeah
you can't do that in Iran so in Iran you
would get in a lot of trouble if you
disobey that so there's political that I
remember when we went to the Middle East
touring I don't think you were with when
I went to Dubai and our friend in
comedian Ahmed Ahmed got in trouble for
making fun of mosque yeah some religious
stuff right so so politically the people
are suffering economically now because
the sanctions are getting more and more
and that's one of the problems with the
strategy that the Trump administration
has taken which is they say we are going
to basically sanction you until you say
mercy so economically the people are
summing because people and then also
socially they're suffering that you
can't go there's no alcohol there's no
but you can't like go out and party
whatever so the people of Iran are fewer
there's no curfew
there are curfews when there's when
there's protests and stuff but I'm
saying in general this is in general the
people of Iran are very educated people
I mean a lot of Iranians are education
is very big in our culture yeah so when
you go I had a friend who was somehow
involved with Stanford he used to say
before this travel ban happened that the
the highest percentage of international
students that would go to Stanford
University to study Electrical
Engineering get their PhDs were coming
from Iran so Iran has all this potential
they have a young they have a young
population that wants to be modernized
nowadays my my hope in terms of any
change in the future in Iran is based on
just the internet the fact that people
in Iran can see everyone else around the
world living their lives and taking dick
pics but yes let's talk about the
internet getting shut down yes there's a
rewind on this to you I mean that's my
worst fear in life I draw the line
during the Arab Spring it was spreading
across the region all this these
protests for freedom and there was a
massive movement in a protest in Iran
and you remember there was this woman no
there was a protest at your time I the
the the green movement in 2009 before
the Arab Spring you said the Arab Spring
Arab Spring was in 2011 with the Arab
countries but in 2009 in the green
movement was when the first massive
protests happened is that when the woman
got yes no no nothing
oooo that might have been I'm talking
about I'm talking about
when Neda agha-soltan II was killed in
Iran not you're not talking about that
one are you I think there was a moment
there was a moment when we were waiting
for Barack Obama to intervene that's
what yeah exact so that was so that was
so in 2009 what happened was the the
elections with MIT Nejad so there's an
election in Iran and the then president
if you remember at my dinner John he's
the one who was saying the Holocaust
never happened he was saying there's no
gays in Iran he's the guy who he was
kind of like our Rd was the Iranian
George Bush now Donald Trump saying
stupid shit and so in 2009 Coulter he RN
culture and so so when when when the
when the elections happened he won
overwhelmingly and the people of Iran
poured into the streets saying that
there's been electric electric and so
when they're pouring in the street doing
these peaceful protests it was called
the green movement and millions of
Iranians are marching in the street and
as an Iranian American I was excited cuz
I was gonna oh my god for the first time
like you were saying Americans are gonna
see Iran ian's in the news and they are
attractive young people protesting and
they're gonna realize that Iran is not
the same country as Iraq and Saudi
Arabia and there is a different country
and they want democracy and then quickly
the government came in and started
shooting into the protesters and they
killed Neda agha-soltan II take it from
there and there was this pressure inside
the US for Barack Obama to do something
for the u.s. to take a stand
because it's crazy I don't remember any
of this I do because I was covering the
White House land and it was an obsessing
moment because it was a moment Barack
Obama started his presidency going to
Cairo and giving this speech saying
freedom and we're gonna be different and
we're gonna stand with the people but
we're not going to impose our will we're
gonna be and this was a moment for him
to do something and intervene and the
administration really effectively didn't
did nothing effectively and there was
this growing pressure ever after that to
do something to help take a stand create
to defuse this decades-old tension
between the u.s. and Iran and push
forward and at the same time what we
haven't really gotten into is the fact
that Iran was developing its own nuclear
weapon and there was this pressure on
the administration as well to intervene
to
stop their program because if Iran gets
a nuclear bomb then this whole region is
like hey the u.s. can't have any control
anymore we can't get the oil we can't
keep the peace and Israel was his like
beside itself to bomb Iran and basically
yeah and stop them from getting this
nuclear bomb because there was this
threat that Iran would actually take out
Israel is the dynamic at play and the
Obama administration was under enormous
pressure to solve this you mentioned
that nuclear scientists were being
killed that's because Israel was doing
these crazy like action movie
interventions where like somebody would
be a motorcycle would come along by your
car put a piece of gum on the car and it
would like they zoom away and explodes
people were like drinking their
Starbucks nuclear physicists and like
dying right so why it was like popping
up out of the pocket no no no no whipped
cream for me in this it's so hard to
fathom maybe we've just seen so many
action movies it's so hard to believe
when life imitates well the Israelis as
you said the Israelis are in the middle
there right there and if Iran is said
that our goal is to destroy you and I
think that Iran and Israel have had this
conflict forever so they're doing things
like this back and forth a lot and I
remember by the way I remember this
green movement moment because we were at
the and why was it just for love meant
it was there were I think that we think
of burning I think there was a green
party not not environmental but the
green party was a more moderate party
who a lot of Iranians felt like wait I
voted for the green guy and he didn't
win and not only did not win but they
quickly put him under house arrest so
the Iranians were going this is listen
this is why it's so copy of the because
the people of Iran want to get rid of
their government yes or they want more
freedom rights and and and then America
is saying as you were saying a lot of
Americans saying well we got to
intervene somehow and I remember we were
at the Just for Laughs festival in
Chicago and I remember because I hosted
a show there you were on the show John
Mulaney was on the show and I remember
that I would be doing the show and then
I would go home and watch the protests
in the streets and I was like oh my god
what's going on and I
lot of Iranians in the West thought this
is it it's gonna change people the the
government's gonna fall and Iranians are
gonna get their freedom back and as you
said I I personally understood
Obama's stand there when he said I don't
want to say anything because the problem
becomes it's such a crazy chess game
where because because McCain McCain at
the time was criticizing Obama going we
need to support these protesters and get
in there somehow and Obama was saying
well if I say I support the protesters
then the government of Iran will quickly
say see America saying they support you
therefore America is behind the
protesters therefore these protesters
should be shot and then you've lost all
it's a very hard game to play you think
he did the right thing I personally at
that point I'm very much this person
who's like listen let's see if we can
work it out diplomatically and so to
come back and see this Iran deal that
happens which we'll get to in a minute
I'm sure as we go through the chronology
I thought the Iran nuclear deal was
something that could have put us on the
path to having because we tried 40 years
of conflict butting heads I said let's
try diplomacy for a little bit and we
got it in place but then Trump quickly
got rid of it and so I think Obama's
policy to go to the diplomacy even
though a lot of Iranians that I know
that when I say this they criticize me
they go no this is Lama Krajina
understand diplomacy they were gonna
take all the money that would have come
in yeah you can't you can't negotiate we
giving them a billions of dollars but I
go but the per I think I think the
strategy would have been to do the
nuclear deal get Iran into this the the
world economy yeah so that now you have
Western companies moving into Iran and
saying whatever Apple is there
Microsoft is there whoever is there and
then if they start violating people say
well aren't you rewarding them but but
but but but then we can say look you got
a taste of the good stuff yeah if you
want us to stay you better play ball if
you don't play ball apples moving out
Microsoft I know that there's cost and
there's time I just thought John Kerry
speaking again about how he said when
the nuclear deal was in in effect their
Iran wasn't launching missiles at Saudi
oil fields we weren't in this kind of a
situation yeah trip I mean we were so
proud
provocative about the way we did it the
way we pulled it out of it then what
happened was after after Israel started
doing these things we taking out the
taking out the US is like okay this is a
little insane let's just do this in a
way where there's not gonna be loss of
life mm-hmm and we deployed the most
effective and extreme cyber attack that
had ever been done to the date which is
called Stuxnet and basically we gave
somebody some flash drive
some like unknowing dude who worked in
the nuclear facility there who then
walks into the secure zone after he got
his Starbucks right and he plugs it into
the system and we release Stuxnet into
their nuclear their uranium processors
and all of a sudden their processors for
you're rich in uranium which is what
makes the material that can be nuclear
used for nuclear bombs they all started
going offline there was all of us on one
after another they're going down and
Iran at first didn't know what happened
and then over time it was called the
Olympic Games it's you know there's now
a book you can read about it etc we
basically attacked their nuclear
capacity without without any loss of
life and the idea was to bring Iran to
its knees simultaneously impose like
Hillary Clinton around the globe and got
all this coalition of countries that are
an unlikely Bunch
to agree to enact the harshest economic
sanctions on Iran to date basically
bleed them so that not only are there
people feeling the pain which causes
political pressure but some of the
elites who love to Globetrotter and get
on private jets and like eat at the Four
Seasons in New York and go to st. Barts
and do their thing all of a sudden their
bank accounts are frozen - and so that
sucks for them and they're actually
pressured to do something so we used all
these techniques to bring Iran to its
knees non-violence yes and it took years
and a lot of like cooperation diplomacy
effort and to finally get to a place
where John Kerry from the Obama
administration then Secretary of State
goes over there and says we're gonna put
together a coalition of countries that
include China and Russia and Germany and
the UK in France we're gonna make a deal
and it's going to say Iran you're we're
gonna lift the sanctions you can build
your economy we can let other
companies come in and start doing
business we're gonna actually unfreeze
money that's been sitting overseas
remember we froze your accounts and
that's what Trump complains about all
the time we gave them a hundred million
dollars to do all these attacks that was
basically saying this hold we have on
your bank accounts is gonna lift and in
return you're gonna do a thing which is
you can keep processing uranium cooking
it effectively up to the level you can
make nuclear power but not know your
bombs and we're gonna come in and
inspect and if we see that you're
cooking it past that level where it can
get to bomb-making material we're going
back to all these bad things we did to
you
but as long as you're good and you keep
it where it is for just energy we're
gonna let you grow your economy and
develop and we're gonna keep it like
this for 15 years I think was like
something like that yes and the idea is
and then we're gonna figure out what to
do next
yeah and that would have allowed Iran
this space to develop its economy
possibly the West thought westernize
modernize let all these companies come
in get its people to a place where the
economy is functioning well and freeze
their nuclear capacity and keep things
out of stasis like at a level where
everybody can get along but you know the
Trump people conservatives people who
are very concerned about Israel's
stability and future what they always
say this sounds you know bad but you
never trust Iran we never trust Iran and
in time they will develop the nuclear
bomb and you're containing their power
you're not limiting it because what
happens after 15 years they're gonna
race to a bomb and if we give them all
this time to think about preparing that
the race to a bomb could happen in
months and then they could it could be
done and so for conservatives and the
very pro-israel groups they felt this
deal was an absolute betrayal sellout
that you're giving them hundred million
dollars to spend on what they want and
let them develop bomb-making capacity
that they can deploy in no time so the
current administration probably didn't
like this going in already had an axe to
grind but with that deal well Trump
hates everything with the name Obama on
it right so he's trying to like undo
everything and what you were saying is
is first of all Iran's stand on the
nuclear stuff number one the Iranian
raishin are the people the government
the administration the regime the the
supreme leader had said it's against
Islam to have a nuclear weapon we don't
want a nuclear weapon now sure as you
said I don't trust them okay but that
said the other thing a lot of Iranians
would argue in Iran they would say well
why is it that all these other countries
are allowed to have nuclear weapons
Israel is allowed to have it Pakistan is
allowed to have it
France whoever else has it why aren't we
allowed to have nuclear energy or
nuclear weapons why and thirdly they
were saying that this program was
started on France had a nuclear weapon
how they do right doesn't France yeah
and so the and then the the the
development of the nuclear program had
been started under the Shah and so
they're saying we've already started
this process we want to fulfill it
now as Jessica was saying the you know
as as Iran became a threat and we wanted
to put some sort of hold on them and we
made the deal we gave them this hundreds
of millions or maybe billion dollars and
there was this image it was a horrible
image it was an image of this crate of
just cash landing in Iran and the
Iranians they you got to realize in
America we've got hardliners we go Hawks
who want to just attack Iran they don't
care about the people they don't care
whatever let's just get rid of this this
these mullahs and then we've got people
that want diplomacy yeah in Iran they
have Hawks who say America is the Great
Satan and then they've gotten moderates
who go we need to cooperate yeah and it
actually benefits a lot of Iranians of
people in power I should say the the
government to go look it's always
America's fault death of the sate and
death of the Satan so when this these
crates of cache land in Iran rather than
just quietly taking the cache which was
originally there as we were holding it
and there was an international court who
had actually said that America needs to
give this money back to Iran and and
Obama always says look we actually got a
good deal if we had given it back with
the amount of interest we were supposed
to give him back it would have been even
more billions of dollars so we gave them
less than we would have had to give back
based on the court and the interest
however if the Iranians hadn't taken
those pictures and posted those
and maybe Americans would have been like
oh this deal was done but because the
pictures were posted guys like Trump are
going look we just gave him a crate of
cash they're gonna now volunteer they're
gonna fund terrorism in the region as
opposed to saying hopefully they're
gonna take this money I don't know what
they gonna do maybe fund terrorism in
the region but more importantly look we
put in this deal that allows us to check
their nuclear program which was the
number one thing again watching John
Kerry talk about it he goes look Iran
still had a lot of stuff human rights
violations yeah their proxies committing
acts of terrorism there's a lot of stuff
we have to go after but he goes at least
we got that one thing I saw Kerry speak
somewhere where he said the good thing
that came out of the diplomacy he goes
right after they had made the deal or
right around the time they were making
the deal Iran captures some sailors in
the Iranian waters America they capture
American sailors in Iranian waters John
Kerry said because of the diplomacy
we've created through the Iran nuclear
deal I was able to call I John Kerry was
able to call his counterpart in Iran is
got him javad zarif as I die you're
taking me out but John Kerry was able to
call his counterpart in Iran and say
look you guys got those sailors they
were they came into your waters it was
enough misunderstanding and he goes
within 24 hours our sailors were
released without any further
misunderstanding day if they captured
ten sailors how would that we would have
contact well we would have to contact it
yes well you know again Karim Sahib or
had an interesting point he goes what
happens if because the way we now
interact we go to the Swiss ambassador
Swiss Embassy is now who is in between
us and Iran so we'd have to go to Swiss
ambassador the Swiss ambassador had to
go to the Iranians the Iranians would
come back to the Swiss guy the Swiss guy
like number Americans and Karine was
saying what happens if as you were
saying with Iran now that they've lost
these missiles in the Iraq nobody got
killed and everyone in America is going
oh thank god
well what happens if in August the
Iranians capture ten sailors exactly and
they say as we're leading
to the elections and they go this is
this a Kareem Saad report what if and
I'm just quoting him here and they say
to Trump they go we will not let these
guys go until all American soldiers are
out of the middle and we just sent
troops over there yeah what happens
so let's oh let's get to what's gonna
happen what might happen what the
predictions are what do you say to
someone who says you know I was on
Twitter obviously you know and and
Twitter is it's the worst of the worst
the best of the best and just chaos in
between and I try to not look and I I
posted something because I had been
posting the ear on things and so many
people were responding like yeah fuck
that guy was such an asshole think like
finally Trump's a hero took him out you
know no what do you say to the people
who are like yeah this guy was an
asshole he you know was terrible to the
Pete he had to go what do you say to
people who think this was a heroic move
on Trump's part and if if Obama did it
would there be a different reaction
happen well my analysis is as a
strategic matter
he was an adversary of the US if you
don't believe in executions then you're
against it altogether if you're gonna
execute yeah he's on the list but the
question is was it worth it and was it
done properly right and we are in was it
legal I mean I'll tell you when I was
when I interviewed President Obama I
think it was in 2012 I asked him he had
never been asked what is the u.s. as
drone policy for executions and what are
your rules and he laid out five terms
that were very specific and very
considered that are really upsetting you
know like nobody wants to hear this
stuff but he said it has to be a target
that's authorized by our laws it has to
be I wrote it down it has to be a threat
that is serious and not speculative has
to be a situation where we can't capture
the individual other civilians have to
be not hit by it and I don't know that
we met all those condition and it has to
be a brown guy one of the top things so
different about this is like I was
saying before he was a member of Iran's
official government not just I don't
want to say a random terrorist but not
around the terrorists right and so in
taking him out we were challenging
the authority of the government of Iran
which we've already established is
enormous ly proud and antagonized by the
West and known to exact retribution
years ago
by accident purportedly our one of our
ships took down accidentally shot down
an Iranian commercial jet killed 290
people Iran to the stock talks about it
every time they confront the US to this
day and still exact retribution for it
and still says we're gonna get 290 back
for it so taking out Soleimani is
inviting enormous retribution the thing
that happened on the base where Iran
didn't kill anybody
I believe it's theater the true
retribution is yet to come
in fact the leader of Iran today said
tomorrow will be a bad day you know so
and Jessica miles will have to go do
what news my sorry what they've
threatened that there will be few the
leaders of run have threatened there'll
be a future action against Americans and
Western forces in the Middle East the
big danger is that we don't know what
their limits will be and how they'll
strike there's one wrinkle which is
because Iran accidentally shot down this
Ukrainian airplane the same day in the
fog of war Oh Donald Trump might be the
luckiest president in our history it's
like I'm fucking believable can I say
it's like un-fuckin'-believable that
this would happen because the fact that
Iran accidentally killed their own
people on this plane has led to so much
anger and unrest in their own country
they don't have the support to attack
the u.s. in this moment had that not
happened the Iranians might actually be
supporting the regime yeah pride so
there was so in the the number one thing
there's two things that I would say that
the killing of Suleyman number one is
like you were saying there's a
constitutional and what precedents does
this set I was talking to my buddies and
Iranian American named Tehran he's a
comedian and he was saying and he was
saying you know does this then allow
China to take out the the
second-in-command of France because they
felt that he was a threat of some sort
because the problem is in trying to say
that this was an imminent threat they
really haven't shown that
how they keep changing the story
teachers it was an attack than its
Embassy's it was forever and the truth
is yes soleimani was probably up to some
stuff and he always is up to some stuff
but but it wasn't imminent the word
imminent is very important here so
number one the precedents that it sets
in terms of taking out leaders of other
countries it was not a terrorist
organization it was someone that we
deemed it won in advance we deemed it
one however end of the day world with
the rest of the world sees this as it's
the guy who is second and you know the
military and the second thing the
strategy of it as you said so here's
that here's a question I again this
reminds me of how I felt when when Bush
went into Iraq and I go strategically
speaking they were though they're
welcome to us with flowers I go no I'm
not a political scientist I could have
told you you're getting rid of the one
guy who's kind of keeping control Saddam
Hussein is a bad guy yeah but he's the
one guy who's kind of keeping everything
under control you can get rid of him
Iran isn't gonna come in and take over
just so you know so in this case I'm
sitting there going what's the strategy
here because I've heard a lot of
people's you know point this out when
you were talk about those protests that
happened in November that you were
getting those tweets people going hey
this shut down the internet and they
were protesting astronomical gas prices
the gas prices were raised and right now
Iran is this like it's it's just this
this tinderbox is just sitting there the
Iranian people are so again the economy
is bad they're fed up and they want to
Instagram the cake and Instagram they
want their freedoms the government is an
oppressive government and so in November
people started protesting against
government in their anger was against
the Iranian government we take out
Soleimani
and quickly at least for whatever that
short period was couple days we were
able to take the anger of the people
that was towards the government and now
all of a sudden the anger the people is
towards America because they're going we
don't like our government but you still
can't come in but you can't do that and
also by the way even if I'm critical of
my government right now I can't go and
say that because my government is saying
you took out our number-two and they're
coming to get you and you just said
you're gonna bomb our cultural sites and
you said the cultural side but you just
now you're just that snotty that's just
that's not at all differentiating the
people of Iran and
culture of Iran with the government of
Iran the government has walked it back
he says walked about not like it's did
it well somebody said listen dum-dum you
can't say that and he was like okay well
it's actually a war crime if they were
to do its war crime but also you're
losing the people that you say you're
supposedly supporting our team in our
culture are different things yeah and
then as Jessica said luck for for Trump
when they take down tragically to take
down the this airplane and what did they
think they were doing oh it's a fog of
war situation I was in I was in touch
with somebody who had been very senior
at the Pentagon and said to me as it
happened this is obviously a
surface-to-air missile from Iran an
accident somebody who doesn't work there
now but he was saying what happens is
you're on high alert they're waiting
they've just attacked bases in Iraq
right they think the US is about to
commit retribution they're waiting for
incoming missiles from the US somebody's
looking at a screen and they see some
projectile moving and they hit it and
they're not seeing that it's going up
and away not down and why would planes
be flying exactly and that's what the
ink right now the people are so angry at
even the supreme leader going you need
to resign a lot of these students are
saying that you need to resign because I
killed a bunch of innocent people you
should have grounded all your blessed
that's that's like you know bombing one
or one to see the planes here it's a
12-hour delay
yeah guys we're not flying for 12 hours
because you know the Americans might be
coming with some shit and then once
that's done you then avoid and by the
way the people who died were a lot of
them were Iranians living in Canada
these young people there was a lot of
like there was there was kids on the
plane there's a lot of just potential
and and just not that people that you
know aren't smart shouldn't die but I'm
just you should die is a heartbreaking
is heartbreaking and the politics of it
are installing
like that it would happen at that moment
kind of handy handcuff to the Iranian
government so now the response will have
to come from these proxies if you want
to talk about so it feels like the the
people of Iran you know gas prices
cutting off our Wi-Fi then you know you
attack we're now not on America side
anymore and now you guys shot down this
plain answer now we're back to being
shoot down the plane and originally my
the originally go yeah it was it was
technical error and I'm come on and it
was crazy because I'll tell you like
talk about Twitter
when I saw reliable sources coming out
because BBC had reported it and and and
it said Iran shot down the plane so I
went and posted something along the
lines of this is tragic and this is the
results of war cuz you can you can
really go back to the the actions of
Iran obviously being being stupid to not
ground the planes secondly Trump's
actions on taking out Soleimani you
could say that that led to the fog of
war and what happened so I just said my
heart goes out to the victims of this
conflict and I posted that and then of
course I get a bunch of people coming at
me going oh you're spreading rumors Iran
hasn't said that that was the case this
is just the West trying to blame Iran
and two days later Iran goes yes it was
us which angers the people even more go
out how could you for two days not take
responsibility even said the US even
admitted it right away when they
accidentally shot down our plane back in
the day right and so it goes it the
weird parallel that we shot down one of
their planes and then they shot down a
plane it's just you couldn't write it
it's it's it's so unbelievable which is
why I need very factual calm news
because it's so enough that if you say
it insane at my brain just shuts down
can I ask you because I think for some
reason become upset like obsessed with
what the Iranians think of all this
because I feel like we don't really hear
their voices very much and I was reading
about how it's impossible to trust the
footage that you see from them because
you have no idea the context of it and
there was a couple of news stations that
were playing these death to America
chants trying to position it as if that
was all Iranians you know they were and
they people say you don't know when this
video was taken you cannot just you also
don't know what kind of pressure people
are under today what they're saying yes
the government's requiring there was a
protest where they were walking across
American flag and everyone was like oh
yeah you know I think people were really
spreading that and you know I'm just how
do we ascertain the public opinion in
Iran is there any way to know well I
think the thing that a lot of Americans
need to understand is that again a lot
of Iranians love America the people of
America and and
you wouldn't always know that based on
what people want to retweet and you
wouldn't know that and also and also a
lot of Americans go well I'm living my
life what do I care like people when the
people go we took out a terrorist who
cares let's move on well know what the
repercussions are the Iranians may
retaliate down the line now somehow we
get drawn into a war now America is back
in a war do we have an appetite for war
I think we have about there about 80,000
Americans in the Middle East right now
in one place or another on bases on
battleships trying to keep the Persian
I'm either piece of this is Iran has
been making skirmishes in the Persian
Gulf that is the main waterway through
which oil moves so if this becomes worse
oil price just like bottom line your gas
is gonna cost a lot more and a lot of
people say they remind you that Trump
came into power saying that I'm against
Wars I want to get us out of there I
want to get us out of there I believe
there's more troops now in the Middle
East than there were when Trump first
came into power and sometimes the
question becomes what if you get painted
into a corner and you have to do
something one of the reasons they say
that Trump took action now is because he
hadn't taken action on a few other
provocations at Iran he needed a
distraction from impeached or you need a
distraction impeachment or he was trying
to please some senators that are hawkish
I mean there's a lot of reasons that
seem to come out askew well this is not
me and my tinfoil hat it's just
something I saw on Twitter were weird of
Saudi Arabia fall into all this how do
you read the ownership with Saudi Arabia
wants to do whatever it can to Crusher
on this I mean this was a great day for
Saudi Arabia when they took out
Soleimani Iran recently attacked Saudi
Aramco which is Saudi Arabia's oil
company I mean Saudi Arabia lives on its
oil it's more than trillion dollar
valued biggest company was bombed
indirectly by Iran and and again this is
what people need to understand is that
these countries in the region don't like
people go oh they hate the Jews no they
hate each other yeah
Sunnis and Shiites don't get along and
the thing with Saudi Arabia that
recently happened was because Saudi
Arabia I think when Trump came into
power a lot of them so the Saudis the
Emiratis the not the Qatar the Qataris
are now the Saudis the the
why do some people say custody honestly
I go down that road I've been told Qatar
Qatar I'm not a big fan of Qatar it
reminds me of Iran Qatar Qatar
it's a Qatar Qatar got the second but my
point is comments but but the point is
the Saudis and the and the Emiratis and
I'm forgetting the third what's the
third part of that coalition there what
GCC countries turning against Qatar it
was Saudis Emiratis not the Kuwait ease
whatever was there's the Sunni the Sunni
Arabs they're isolated or have a
conflict with Iran and what happened was
as you said when Trump came into power a
lot of them thought oh this is great
Trump is gonna get rid of Iran or you
know we can Iran somehow as a matter of
fact Saudi and the Israelis we're
talking to each other the Bibi Bibi and
an MBS
were suddenly you think oh they're
supposed to be arch-nemesis but no they
were they were like because they you
know the enemy of my enemy is my friend
right so they were both against Iran but
then what happened was when Iran bombed
the Saudi oil fields and America didn't
do anything
Saudi Arabia started going wait a minute
this was a blast so then so then then
the Saudi started saying maybe Trump
does not have the stomach to go to war
and overthrow Iranians so the Saudis
were just starting to open up diplomacy
with the Iranians and as a matter of
fact the Emiratis the Saudis and the
Iranians are fighting each other in
Yemen and the Emiratis had sent some
soldiers but then recently the Emiratis
UAE Dubai those guys they were like you
know what this this shit ain't working
out
we're yeah now there's one thing to keep
in mind that makes it super complicated
and one of the reasons it's not already
I know maybe Trump didn't take action
against Iran after they bombed the Saudi
oil fields is Iran is a very close ally
of Russia so Putin is not happy about
what about taking out Soleimani but
Trump and Putin are so one would
antagonize Putin if one takes out
Soleimani so that was really a
surprising move in that regard as well
from Trump but also isn't in the
maybe you can shed light on this isn't
it doesn't this play into Putin's hands
because now it makes Iran turned it to
Russia even more like Putin's going I'm
your guy you know what you a chess game
it just creates more chaos and
destabilizes the region and that's
Putin's play which is he just wants as
much instability and if Iran's running
into their arms and they're gonna start
as one might expect proxy attacks and
antagonizing the entire region
that's great both for Putin's interests
and for their oil exports because the
Russians and the Iranians were working
together in Syria to help Bashar
al-assad so make you a map and tell you
I'm just like nodding here's what I can
contribute to this conversation I had
movers here this past weekend and they
were Russian and I was asking him all
these questions about Putin cuz I'm just
obsessed with him and no so what's the
deal with Putin like do I'm always
curious what information we're getting
and not getting and you know cuz I think
we all had this idea that all Russians
like are obsessed with Putin he's like
no some of us don't like it's like Trump
but we some like some don't right and I
was exposed to deal with Putin he goes
most Russians think that he's an actor
because he stayed so young for so long
he played by Robert Duvall and who's
behind him oleg art yeah and that it's
an actor that is looks like him and got
a bunch of surgery to look like it's not
really know they're really because he's
been 45 days have a lot of Botox yeah
nothing we all just assume he's an actor
and it blew my mind and also but that
did happen in Poland apparently there
was a whatever their government is I
don't know had a twin brother oh and
they stepped in right I mean an in
Ukraine now you have an actor who's
actually president so what is who knows
maybe the whole we had an actor be our
governor I mean there's the Wayans
brothers where's the rock we really
wanted to run but it's funny you ask
that question of the rescued whenever I
can I ask people and I had started as
one guy who's a professor on Russia and
I said how do the Russians feel about
hacking the election it was they're
proud of it because they're like we got
a merit you know what we are big strong
your big stupid it's just it's it's so I
the main thing I want to ask now and if
you can't necessarily answer this
because I know you're real journalists
what should we expect what do you
predict I have friends that are like we
shouldn't fly we got to take all our
cash out we got about under our mattress
a lot of my friends are actors they're
very dramatic and we gotta you know make
one of those playing Putin yeah yeah so
how scarce should we be you know I think
this there's just this general Aang's
generalized anxiety a lot of people are
you know is it histrionic to say we're
in World War three we're at war like I
just need to know how to feel and how
scared to me I mean my personal
assessment is if there's going we're at
a place of such global instability that
all it takes is one little thing to go
off one match took a bit loopy lit that
can cascade into a war we did a great
job of backing off from it in this past
moment but I don't think this is the end
of the Orani in response I think that
they know Donald Trump is fixated on the
Iranian hostage crisis which was when a
bunch of Americans were held captive by
Iran and he saw that Jimmy Carter seemed
helpless in taking action and you know
has always obsessed even in private life
he would talk about the powerlessness
the weakness of Jimmy Carter and how
Ronald Reagan came in and did something
if you want to get back at Donald Trump
one way to do that is to take a couple
Americans hostage somewhere Mike so
that's a thing and that's just specific
to Trump I mean it was a bad thing in
general and a better point in history
but he you know how he fixates on
certain moments this is one of his
things
yeah he obsesses over and so now some of
my friends who are more you know work in
the national security space to say that
if Americans were to be taken hostage it
would so trip Trump that he would just
go so over the top and response that
Iran might not do that because maybe
Tehran wouldn't really survive that so
well so I don't know what they'll do
like things that are on the table and
they've even said are you know as tax on
US and Allied forces or EU forces in the
region what you proposed which is what
if they do something to say all troops
out because they said they're going to
make action
to push all of the US troops out of the
region the other things they can do are
more skirmishes in the Persian Gulf to
drive up gas prices
my guess is any of this would happen
much closer to the election when it
would have more of an impact and the US
would have less time to respond we don't
know how that would play politically
because you know you could imagine Trump
doing something to show force and act
tough and there is this rally around the
leader effect ahead of an election when
our leader does something in a you know
shows military force often that
increases their poll numbers the will
add that on the politics the Senate and
the House has passed a measure to limit
Donald Trump's war-making ability
without going to Congress first in
response to this in response it just
happened and the US Senate Democrats and
Republicans in the US Senate say they
have the votes to do the same which is
unusual in this moment but that they
would have 51 votes for Republicans are
signed on to pass something that says
we're not saying you can't do it but if
you're gonna do something come to us
first because the Constitution says you
have to yeah I have friends who you know
like I said a lot of a lot of Iranians
actually like Trump because of what he
did they they go that was good that he
took out soleimani and he's gonna stand
up to this regime and somehow get rid of
them and it's funny so a lot of them go
they go you know well these lower taxes
I go he's heightened anxiety I have not
like this past week 20/20 feels like
it's been a year and year I have not
been on eggshells like this for so long
especially as a stand-up comedian I'm
not an accountant yeah if I were to
count it I'd be like I'm going to work
I'm set I don't know what's gonna happen
instead of commedia I'm like how do I
become funny and tell jokes when I'm
Iranian American yeah these two
countries are gonna go to war and
there's so many mixed emotions of course
I want the people of Iran to have their
freedoms of course I would love for this
regime to somehow disappear and have a
democratic government yeah come into
Iran but but I know that that's gonna be
a lot of bloodshed unless if we need an
off-ramp and my hope is some off ramps
start showing themselves and and right
now it hasn't and possibly it could be
other countries like Germany and France
and other countries getting in the
middle and going right right now they're
currently trying to get Iran back into
the nuclear deal Iran said Iran when
America pulled out of the nuclear deal
Iran stayed in it but recently because
of the killing of slowly monitor said
we're out yeah and now the Europeans are
saying come back in but they're saying
for what what do we have to come back in
for but I'm hoping that there's some
off-ramp there's some that's why I
really wish we would have given this
nuclear deal give it like three years
four years see how it goes and again I
understand the argument that a lot of my
Iranian American friends make they go
you can't negotiate with these mullahs I
go well so tricky about it is you're
like how do you find a common ground
with someone whose values are so well
you hope you hope that the people of
Iran you see there's little things that
were happening little just little things
like for the longest time women weren't
allowed into soccer stadiums will just
laugh that was just last year I think
they were starting to allow them and
there's been a whole movement to like
you know women are mandatory men it's
mandatory for women to cover their hair
in Iran the Iranian women are so
fashionable that the way they do it
there's always hair coming out but
there's been a movement to take off the
the hijab and say it should be my choice
so I I mean and and you know I think
that people might expect me to chime in
on this I have stopped doing that
because actually when I went to Dubai
this was what 12 years ago or something
right you know and I went up there were
these young girls that you know had it
on at a mall and you know I walked up to
them you know the American arrogant you
know and I was like I mean why would you
you know cuz some women had it some
didn't it was Dubai no so why would you
choose this are you okay to need help
and they're like no we literally we
choose this and then she lectured me on
how American women are oppressed because
of we got plastic surgery and the eating
disorders and you know interesting point
it empowered argue and like we're valued
on our you know personalities and
opinions and not our appearance and and
I just got schooled so I was like you
know what I'm not gonna weigh in on that
anymore
yeah you're right and it's and and so I
but the foundation is choice and you're
saying increasingly my mission was
having choice yeah founders choice and
it's also
hopefully the change coming from within
now again these guys you know quoting
Kareem Sajit poor again he was saying
how what you said early on the Shahs
there's a another book that's a good
book is called all the Shahs men the
Shahs men were all West you know
generals and and and people who would
either been Western educator or their
kids were setting in the West so when
the revolution happens these guys all
have homes in England and in France and
in America and then get up and flee
you know Kareem Suraj report was
pointing out how this current regime
although they have sent their kids
there's different places in the world
using their money that they've been
embezzling that's one of the other
things this government has embezzled a
lot of money and it's just you know
living large while their people are
starving it's horrible but but the P but
they are they they themselves like ha
made the supreme leader doesn't have a
place to go so he's not gonna flee I
think I heard you talking about is this
called the dictators dilemma the
dictators dilemma that's what he was
saying you explain what that is
well I asked is Kareem I go why doesn't
I go the guy's 80 years old I go so why
doesn't he look or Instagram leader now
Korea supreme leader now is 80 years old
why does he look at the situation go
look my people are angry at me because
of the downing of the plane I'm gonna
find an excuse
maybe my health is getting worse I'm 80
I'm gonna go to a Sandals you could go
to Africa like et I mean did or to
Russia go to Africa hang out with
Snowden in Russia just just get I just
get out and in Kareem said that no one
Rogan yeah and and and he said the
dictators dilemma is that when they get
out of power than they are going to be
prosecuted and held account because they
did international war crimes because of
the crimes because of what they did in
their own country I mean that's what
happened with our buddy in Egypt yeah
whose name ybarra and this is one of the
reasons Iran wants a bomb because if you
look at what's happened to the countries
that gave up their bomb or gave up their
weapons like Muammar Qaddafi he gave us
his weapons right and then we killed him
in a water tunnel with a drone you know
and so after he's surrounded he
surrendered them and then we killed him
so Kim jong-un who
has these weapons is like uh ain't
giving them to yeah yeah yeah yeah and
that's one of the reasons Iran is like
we want our weapons we're not going to
cut a deal that says we won't have them
cuz the dictate that's part of this ya
dilemma have you talked unto your
friends that are in Iran now I have some
distant relatives in Iran I can hit up
all the time on Instagram the same way
you were talking about like I get a ton
of people sending me videos of but you
don't know if it's real I don't know
it's hard to verify I don't know if it's
real we don't care you need to talk to
someone on the ground yeah yeah but even
is like listen that was my deal III know
I don't I didn't realize so afterwards I
was just like I don't even know if this
is real I mean young people with the
resident doesn't seem to mind so the
president doesn't mind I have the same
values as the president great there's
one others oh good no I was just going
to say you know I am a lot of the videos
I actually didn't post I mean some of
the ones and I think part of the reason
I'm you know my heart you know breaks
for this situation I mean it should for
anyone but I saw some videos that I
didn't post that were so brutal and
incomprehensible of what was going on in
terms it's horrible it's a brutal regime
I mean that what they do is they there's
no human rights and so it is very brutal
and and there are a lot of people that
that are suffering under this regime and
that's why it becomes so sensitive
because whatever you post you're gonna
get someone from some side cuts right
first of all how did you know this video
is real why you oh you're out by point
by by posting this you're making you
sort of the Hawks will win in America
and then attack Iran I'm going no that's
not what I want I'm just trying to say
that these can I criticize the leaders
of Iran and the leaders of America at
the same time yeah and so they can't can
they can't really protest that's just
illegal in general and what is the
punishment if you do no no they protest
and the protests get bigger and bigger
and then they the regime has been
sending out their people from from this
called the best siege which are these
the besieged are people who were trained
to keep the Islamic Revolution alive so
back then home a knee one thing he did
that was smart for him he said you know
as he didn't necessarily trust the the
military he said we need to have our own
military to help again the religion
imagine if the religious right goes
we're gonna get a bunch of
brain what brain watching a bunch of
people say you're with the regime you're
with the religious right and we're gonna
also pay you money and we're gonna make
sure you're taken care of
and anytime protests happen we want you
to get your batons and get your guns get
on the back of these scooters go to the
protest and just start beating people
they protest that crackdown they protest
a crackdown and this one time they
started actually killing people so it's
like it's a tinderbox - it's really a
tinderbox there's one weird twist that
could happen there's no evidence that's
going to but I feel like with Trump
anything's possible
he needs a dramatic moment he needs
another summit summits with the North
Korea aren't that exciting anymore
because we've seen that show before so
one could imagine him doing a 180 and
saying sit down with me let's just have
a talk let's do diplomacy I don't think
they're there I don't think he'll do it
but it's so crazy right now I feel like
anything also I don't think that Iran is
will do it they don't like him they
don't trust them brainless if that you
the Americans say all these
preconditions are off the table that's
what so they could play that game yeah
that could be where we're headed you
must do this will do give you that blah
blah well that's the problem with the
administration because mock pom-pom
Pompeo goes goes in front of the cameras
and goes oh we're willing to talk to
Iran we're totally Iran doesn't want to
talk to us it just need to abcdefg and
Iran's like wait a minute you saying we
gotta get rid of our whatever our you
know nuclear stuff we've got to stop you
know get rid of our funding of these
proxies we have they basically made it
so that it's impossible for Iran to come
to the table and then they sell it as
we're trying to talk they don't want to
talk you know or in this case with the
solely money thing it was imminent we
had to do it well where's the imminent
thing like there was i I was hearing
some reporting saying that you know when
Trump said it was that they were gonna
hit four embassies somebody was saying
that the reporting show that there was
none of those embassies had been there
was no warnings to any embassy staff
that something's coming down but usually
when there's something that occurred so
the head of the Defense Department said
he wasn't aware of it but he but
believes Trump like it's yeah well it's
tricky I mean it's tricky because that
you know I was talking to someone who
used to be in the FBI in DC who said
like yeah but you also can't give people
a heads up when you're doing something
like this you
right but you do need to tell your
embassy staff that hey some shits coming
down the pipeline and maybe minutes
before hour before get out of the
embassy yeah there's an attack coming
and we're getting the guy a matter of
fact again the I read something about
the whole the whole the way the whole
Solomonic thing went down I guess he was
he was there waiting for him yeah he was
and he was late he was flying into Iraq
and he was late to his plane and then
the you know the the people that they
were getting ready to attack were
getting a little worried going oh is he
is he not gonna come is he gonna come
and he was notorious for waiting for
whatever plane is borning to get there
last minute
sit in the front land get out and get
going and by the way they killed another
guy who was an Iraqi militia leader and
the he ran the splinter groups in Iraq
that are attacking US forces in Iraq
those guys have taken revenge for their
guy yet we so we got a twofer two of
America's adversaries were taken out in
the same shot a hot heel yeah but we
didn't know if he was going to get
picked up by that dude or by some like
family and civilians and so they were
kind of on if you ever watched homeland
hot alert like the person deciding to
make the call based on who in that
picture is actually getting out of the
car to greet him
and we were also trying to kill another
Iranian leader at the same time I forget
where he was in Yemen or something yeah
he wasn't in Iran I think it might have
been Yemen yeah there's another guy that
we were we were gonna take out as well
the same day missed
we missed yeah yeah I know that is my
guess I think so if you see a missile
flying over your head like whoa that
plane got close wait okay I don't know
if they shot at him or not while taking
out Soleimani we also took out an
important aspirin in Iraq yeah and they
haven't even an important guy that was
part of one of the proxies in Iraq so
just time at war for a second it's such
a weird thing to say war is such a vague
term and it makes it makes me envision
people like on a field with right you
know it may be maybe 1970 Donal II war
is different now aka cyber it can be you
know germ it can be so many things and
we call it sometimes you hear people say
there's kinetic action
so there's kinetic action right now in
Ukraine
between Ukrainian troops and Russian
troops that's war they're like in a hot
war we just like to not call it that
because war sounds big but it's it's
like this guy versus this guy attacking
each other to the death to win isn't
that work and also war no matter how you
haven't even this beautiful clean war
that we've been able to create with our
drones and no Americans are gonna get
killed a cetera cetera
the repercussions of it I mean you could
make the argument that Isis came out of
the Iraq war sure right so similarly
speaking if we were to go because one of
the things one of the other ideas that
I've heard before is that when Saddam
was in conflict with Iran Iran is like
you said 80 million people but there's
many different factions there's in the
north there there turkish cause Ares
there's the Kurds there's Arab base the
Iranians so there's groups within Iran
that don't get along with each other as
well I mean they literally Iran but they
don't yeah so one of the ideas was to
foment a civil war in Iran between five
factions and let them just go at it
right right right right and so what
happens if a civil war happens in Iran
well what will happen is it'll be
similar to what's happening in Syria
you're gonna get a lot of refugees
you're gonna get a lot of bloodshed
you're gonna get people joining
hopefully possibly you know terrorist
attacks so war is not clean in any way
and there's no war is just a bad thing
if we can avoid war yeah we're in a good
place again to me that goes back to me
saying like I wish we would have given
diplomacy a chance and I hope there's a
diplomatic solution out of this I just
feel like that we haven't seen a new
kind of war yet do you know what I mean
with a technology we have available I
think we're seeing it unfold and what
could come next is something we can't
imagine yet I mean we're just an
unchartered territory yeah I mean Iran
one of the things they have is our cyber
bombs which aren't actual bombs but
planted in our infrastructure they took
a dam offline in New York previously and
so I mean this dam is like water it
means it means like one day your lights
work and then the next day LA has no
power
yes cyberattacks
that makes me anxious a shit I know I
feel that saying it because it's like oh
my life's aren't gonna work the me I
know dear you insane it's a pot is gonna
be down I mean that's so we just have no
idea what to expect itself and it should
we be I just think you should be I mean
listen that hopefully again you you try
to live your life in a you know worrying
about the normal things that you need to
worry about but but you just don't know
I mean the Soleimani thing I didn't see
it comin did you see a comment I mean I
don't think Trump's own administration
so is crazy reaction I mean oMG WTF you
guys I mean like that's when you're just
and did this really happen is this a
thing like or we do what III think that
we again I don't want people to be I
don't think people should be living
their lives saying like oh I'm gonna get
hijacked or kidnapped or whatever unless
you put yourself in some weird situation
but that said we don't know what's
coming down down the pipeline and I do
hope I got I got I got a little hopeful
when Iran retaliated the way they did
but I know that in the back of their
minds they're like we're coming again
and then obviously the tragedy of this
flight was just beyond belief I mean
it's just the the fact that that
airplane went down but had that been an
American aircraft it would have gone
down also well if we're an American at
one thing Iran would be standing if that
what did they think it was well listen
they got a shooter we're gonna know but
they didn't think it was an American
passenger plane they thought it was the
Americans retaliating right in which
case that not with American soldiers on
it they thought it was a missile god oh
god I got it got it got it
but even if American soldiers were on it
if you're coming at me I'm gonna listen
they were ready to go American soldiers
that were coming we got to do what we
got to do okay Qi trigger finger is what
happened the other thing that Justin
this isn't better but you know for
people who are listening in the US what
Iran has been clear about is that if
they're going to do a bloody attack it
will be on troops in the Middle East so
it doesn't sound like they're coming
domestically is the most likely outcome
but that's what you would want people to
think you've an
you're right I still want you to feel
okay if you go to a Persian restaurant
we have great food West Boulevard
there's Daria the shamshir there's have
you been a Raffi's place in Glendale
delicious
get some water have some peanut butter
yeah that idea follow Jessica Yellin on
her Instagram Twitter am I missing
anything
YouTube that's YouTube oh great Moz I'm
at Maz Jobrani Twitter Instagram I've
got my podcast called back to school
where you stuff out you have experts
come on scholars come on yeah it's a
it's we try to be funny we try to learn
and it's free it's free some people
should watch it and or lol yes and also
I'm on tour so people are in in United
cities I'm going all over the place I'll
be in DC I'll be in Atlanta with a model
band tour travel ban to go to Bosnia
brawny calm you can catch me in a
holding cell any questions that y'all
have that I missed I'm sure I missed a
lot of really smart questions I wrote
down a bunch of things I tried really
hard to get to everything and I
certainly feel like I can go to a dinner
and not sound completely stupid and
follow everybody is there anything I'm
missing anyone first bonus episode I
feel smarter and slightly scared er this
is great Jessica Yellin hashtag news not
noise I'm stealing her breath yeah
[Music]